mince mais pardon quoi il y a pas des
sujets plus importants que stigmatiser
les étrangers Philippot
et j'accueille maintenant Gaspard Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
ça
fait du bien d'arriver sur tant d'amour
partagé pendant une heure
moi je vais pas parler les sujets
immigrations tout ça non léonarda ah
ouais non mais la meuf la déstabiliser
le pays ça a eu des répercussions
terribles sur plein de secteurs Nabilla
ne dort plus
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
contrairement à Nabilla qui a choisi les
paillettes léonarda a choisi l'école
c'est normal
elle a quand même du se rendre compte
que pour faire escort c'était pas gagné
une avance quoi
non mais
moi en tout cas j'espère qu'elles vont
pas trop style la bourre parce qu'après
une qui veut faire le buzz l'autre que
faire le contrebasse parce que Nabilla a
récemment a fait ça au grand journal
elle a montré elle a écarté son entre
cuisse et on a vu son le toboggan à
miosqueonarda et la même idée je veux
dire on reçoit déjà assez d'images
violentes de Siri tu vois
alors Jean Vincent placé a réagi c'est
le seul qui réagi c'est le seul qui a
fait on va faire des manifs de lycéens
pour manifester pour son retour bon
c'est un peu normal sauf que leonardin
il a tout d'une militante Europe
Écologie le sexe à pile de Duflot la
syntaxe des va-jolie et la moustache de
Noël
je dis ça attention je vois je vois que
lennel me scrute avec ce petit œil mais
parce que mince mais pardon quoi il y a
pas des sujets plus importants que
stigmatiser les étrangers Philippot
c'est insupportable cette quête du bouc
émissaire bonjour petit mouton de l'Aïd
voir l'autre comme un problème alors
qu'il peut être une solution
aux chutes attention Bambi traverse le
plateau
c'est une honte Ardisson de ce qui se
passe de foulée au pied ces grands
principes que sont le droit du sol quand
je vois chez moi chaque jour ma femme de
ménage le lustrer avec passion
notre pays c'est un grand pays et on
peut faire des choses comme dirait je ne
sais plus si tu es Sartre
non mais nous sommes la République
pardon pardon le creuser republicain ça
existe la grande cocotte nationale qui
agglomère tout c'est pas rien on
pourrait pas se rassembler un peu non
mais tout le monde s'il vous plaît pour
pas un peu tout y est agglomérer notre
vivre ensemble dans la fraternité il est
temps que le peuple de France se lit il
faut que les Français féculent
oui l'immigré c'est quoi c'est la
maïzena du lien social
on a tous vocation à être un flageolet
du Grand cassoulet national je vous le
dis moi
bisounours qui mange une compote avec un
lion
est-ce que ce sont vraiment les
étrangers qui sont responsables d'après
Philippot c'est les étrangers qui sont
responsables de prendre de la France on
veut nous faire croire que la famille de
leonarda abusé de la France que la voie
du travail pardon au contraire elle en a
donné à la CAF au conseil général
à Manuel Valls
à la police des airs et des et on
voudrait se couper de ses relais de
croissance
[Rires]
vu la coccinelle
moi quand moi quand je vois le périple
de cette famille qui affrontait les
dangers pour rejoindre la France de son
Italie natal traverser les Abruzzes la
plaine du pot les orcs du pays du Mordor
les dragons les agents de Saroumane le
gris l'œil de Schengen qui voit tout qui
surveille tout
et ils ont évité jusqu'à l'arrivée dans
le Doubs pays des hobbits
je sais pas encore si c'est oui c'est ça
c'est une licorne qui accouche
nous le pays de Hugo on se refuserait à
accueillir des petites énergies
non mais s'il vous plaît les dipranes
sont innocents voilà une famille que
toute sa place en France à la télé aussi
mais pas la rubrique fait divers mais
dans une famille en or
ou une famille en cuivre je ne sais pas
il faut être sérieux alors on peut se
poser peut-être une seule question la
seule question que personne n'a posé ces
gens qui viennent pour intégrer un pays
plus riche qui veulent offrir à leurs
enfants des meilleurs écoles qui veulent
gagner plus d'argent pour progresser
socialement et montrer aux pays
d'origine qu'ils ont réussi la seule
question que je me posais mais est-ce
que la France a les moyens d'accueillir
tous ces gens de droite
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça mais passons à autre chose
international les USA espionne toujours
et encore la France tu m'étonnes avec
l'affaire léonarda dans un monde aussi
directrice c'est quand même dommage pour
les Américains de se priver de tel barre
de rire
bon maintenant qu'ils ont été découvert
les Américains tremble ah oui quelles
vont être les représailles parce que
Hollande il va
interdire la parade de Mickey oui
expulser macronade du territoire proposé
à une fille Obama de venir étudier en
France mais sans ses parents je sais pas
cocasse un Iranien condamné à mort
survit à sa pendaison
alors non c'est vrai à la mort il paraît
qu'il respirait encore c'est inquiétant
ça fait 40 ans que l'Occident se fait
menacer par un pays qui ne sait pas
faire un nœud coulant
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Cantat affirme j'ai commis l'irréparable
pourquoi il a fait un duo avec la fouine
[Applaudissements]
détendons un peu l'atmosphère un chinois
a tué sa soeur à coup d'altère c'est le
fitness à la chinoise quoi tu fais un
exercice tu perds 55 kg
bonne nouvelle au cinéma sortie de
Gravity donc c'est l'histoire de deux
individus qui l'évite dans leur bulle
au-dessus de la réalité en France on a
la version longue elle dure 5 ans voilà
pas belle la vie et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditube abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu